I don't know if I'm supposed to be able to--
*Markimoo Mating Call*
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to "Unforgiving: A Northern Hymn".
Now I played this game as a demo a while back,
and it scared the pants off of me.
There was a giant troll in the woods, and it was HORRIFYING.
But now, the full game is released.
Now I don't know if the opening of this game is going to be the same as the original.. demo...
It might be. And if it is the same then I'm actually going to play through it--
Oh...
OH.
Well that's not good.
Oh-WAH.
Hey-- oh
Hoo!
Hey this is-- uhh-- this not the same.
Okay...
Well...
*man speaking swedish*
*What dialect is this?!* *Im glad you asked, other subtitler. Its Swedish*
OH!! WHOA! WHOA!! DEATH?!
AY HEYHEYHEYHEYYYY!!
EAT SHIT DICK BAG!!!
oh..
Okay...
Alright...
Well!...
I don't know what's happening but I'm glad I kicked that guy in the back of the head!
Ooohh..
Oh no...
Oh no, where am I?
Hello?
WHEAAAYYYHHH..
Uh-oh...
Oh God dammit...
WWUUUGGHHH
You want another kick?
Euughh..
OOH...
WHATDOYOU--WHOHO-- WHA--?
What did-- That's-- That's--
my BROTHER?!
WHAT DID-- WHAT?!
WHAT DID--? PFFPHH
What did he expect would happen you try to get I thought I thought?
What did he expect would happen?!
You try to get-- I thought-- I thought--
that I-- YOU were just some HORRIBLE person--
and you were kidnapping me! And you're still a horrible person for kidnapping me!!
Okay-- pffhuheheh!
I don't think your actions are justified at all!..
I didn't see your face, I didn't recognize you,
BRO.
Ohhh yeah..
But this seems bad being out here in the middle of the woods with her- Ohhh...
But this seems bad. Being out here in the middle of woods where there's--- Ohhh...
Okay.. Alright. Where are you going, buddy?
Euuhh...
So what is my-- uhh-- quote on quote problem that you're trying to stage an intervention about?
What would- uh- what would you say if you just hadda--
shout it at the top of your lungs in the middle of a crowded forest?
Just go ahead and whisper it in my ear.
Wai-Wait!!-- But if-- I mean if we crashed the car we couldn't be too far from it!
Euuhh
Now we're bonding!
Okay!
I guess you are my brother, so--
OH...
UH- Bro?
Uh, Bro you might want to watch out about the strings, I just heard in the distance...
You might want to watch about the strings I just heard in the distance.
What are you gonna do? Something stupid?
What are you going to do? Something stupid?
OK.. Alright! Okay! Yeah!
Okay, all right. Okay. Yeah! Push the giant tree. Yeah, push. It real good, man
PUSH A GIANT TREE! YEAH! PUSH IT REAL GOOD!
Man!
Pff! I'll help, I guess!
I'll help I guess. Hiyah!
Hiyaah!
EyyyYAAHH!
Hiyah!
We're so strong! Oh, there. Now I'm helping. I wasn't helping before.
We're so strong!
Oh! There! Now I'm helping!
I wasn't helping before...
Ahh, welp...
alright. Heheh.
Goodness gracious, you uprooted that thing. Alright. Well, off I go then. Me first, I suppose.
Goodness gracious, you uprooted that thing.
Oh well, off I go then! Me first I.. SUPPOSE!
Yeah, it seems safe. Good maneuver there, bro.
Yeah, this seems safe! Good maneuver there,
BRO.
Alright. Bro?
Alriiight..
Bro?
Careful, Bro!
Careful, bro. Why duh? I don't want to know what that maneuver was in the middle of tha- Hey!
PFFWHAHA! WHYDON--
I don't wanna know what that maneuver was in the middle of there-- WHEY!!!
Yeah, we're not gonna-- we're just gonna ignore the fact that that sounded like a scream?
Is this an "Until Dawn" situation, where everyone just ignores EVERYTHING?!
EYYAH YADDAH YADDAH YADDAH AWAY
'T WEREN'T NOTHIN'!
't weren't ah - 't weren't a whole lotta nothin'!
It definitely- ehnn..
-gasp-
Alright, nothin'.
Nothin'...
Ah good, yes! Crouch!
Oh! I'm always careful! You shut your face.
I know what I'm about.
Me and my ADDICTION are totally fine!!
YOU don't need to get in the way of ME, and whatever the hell MY ADDICTION is!
Drugs?
Sex maybe? I dunno!
Water?
Uh-huh. Okay. Sure yeah.
You learn something.
"How far we got swept away"?!
I guess that explains my earlier question, but I still don't buy it!
A bunCHA phony baloney-- I heard that.
I heard that alright...
Ohh..
MM! Good! Yes!
There's referees in the woods!
Whistlin'!
Uggh..
Oh.
Ah- Ooahh...
Ah ooo...
Ah! OH!
That- OOO!
Eyy ohh-- ooo..
A phphphhrr!
That was a rumbly bumbly!
Hey! Wait! Agh! EGH! Dude!!!
BRO!
WHA--!?
I don't--!!
Stop tap dancing for one second and look at the doll!
Pinned into the tree!
Which is probably BAD!
Bro?!
Could you stop for a second and look at all the bullshit that's happening in front of you?!!
DAAAAHHHH-- I HATE THAT!
AAAlright, Bro!
Yeah, don't mind me just SCREAMIN' behind you.
Probably sick of my shit...
I'm addicted to talkin' out my ass, that's what I'm addicted to...
Euuh.
Well, I can see some things...
They look like horrible shadows and shapes...
Uh- wh-OH- There you are!
I thought I lost you.
-long inhale of fear-
Someone else is knocking a tree down to make a bridge.
OH!
Someone already did,
Bro...
Euuhuhhzzz..
BROOO!!
BROOOO???!!
I DON'T LIKE THIS,
BROOO..
BROOOOOO!
Alright,
Bro.
I trust you,
Bro...
Nope! Ah! Stop mentioning the Goddamned camp!
Who's playing the xylophone out there?!
Who's got a harp and a xylophone?!
Why are there so many orchestra members lost in the WOODS?!
Oh, good a cave. Yeah this is going to be my FAVORITE thing...
Oh no it's not a cave it's just an overhang.
Oh, God- Okay! Alright! It's getting better!
I'd like to think that any time someone from any sort of concert,  or choir or an orchestra
if they get lost in the woods- just to reassure themselves- they start playing in a creepy manner.
It's like, "If I'm the scariest thing in the wood no one can kill me!"
Haha!
"Everyone's going to stay AWAY!!"
...get out demon...
Bro,
I, uhh..
Someone just screamed...
But,
Bro!
Do you not hear those drums?
Ahh! The choir!!
We found them!
BROO!!!
BROOOO?!!
UH-
BROOOO??!!!
OOhh-kay.. Alright...
Nevermind,
Bro.
There's a lot of musical cues happening,
Bro,
that my-my gamer instincts are kicking in about.
And then suddenly it's a whole lot of NOTHIN'.
AAEEHH.
Bu-de-bu-be-de-bah-do-BEH-beh-de-dube--
Okay! Alright-
Bye
BRO.
I-- I think this where we never see each other again.
Okay...
Goodbyyeee... OH!
OOhhh-WHY-AYY!!??!!
AGGHHH!!
Okay, alright, well! We are-- Oh hi,
BRO!
Jeez! Alright... well hello...
Ah! Moose!
Good old fashioned dead MOOSE!
Well, we might- we might wanna skedaddle,
BRO.
Listen,
Bro...
I dunno, just keep it between you and me, but I think- uhh...
I think there might be a monster in these woods. For all I know we could've been--
LOOPING THROUGH THE SAME SEGMENT OF WOODS!!
I saw something up there! Did you see something?! I saw something!
Ah no, it was a log- never mind it was a branch!
Is it a TROLL?!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S A TROLL AND WHAT'S A BRANCH!
Where's all the shrubbery gone?!
There's only trees and no bushes! :,(
What kinda weird ass woods is these?!
I don't know what's going on,
Bro,
but you better!--
Bro...
Alright.
I keep going crazy, 'cause I keep going like, "AH IT'S A THING!" And it's NOTHING, and I don't like it!
Oh, there's the shubberAYYY!!
Alright,
Bro...
Bro,...
start talking about camp. I'm starting to become a little bit PERTURBED..
I liked it better when you droned on and on about CAMP!
I- ke-dr-AHHH!!
Stop doing that again!
Don't do that!
Oh! Another of the pushing tricks eh? Well, what good is that gonna do? It's not going to reach all the way across...
Alright, whatever you say,
Bro.
Let's do this together,
BRAH.
O-Okay! Here we go!
Let me wipe the moose blood on this tree here.
Okay, what good did that do? It didn't-
Oh yeah, me, me, me, yeah me! All me.
All me, baby.
All me.
WAHH!
UH-OH!
WELP!
HEH! BYE,
BRO!!
WHAT?! NO! Just jump it! It's not that bad!
Jump! Ah, well it is pretty fast, alright-...
Well, okay, alright then...
See ya, around!
See ya!
I guess...
Uhwee-- Oh ho ho!
See I could jump! You can jump too!
Alright. See ya,
Bro...
I'm alone now...
All by myseeellfff...
Just with the orchestraaaa...
Gonna go well for me,
BRO.
I feel saaafe!
OH!
Bro!
There you are! Okay, alright...
Brooo...
Hi,
Bro..
Okayeheh.. Alright see ya.
Okay, okay! Good luck! Alright, you don't die either because apparently there's many ways for you to die around here!
Alright, see ya
BRO!
Okay, all on my own. Now who's going to talk to me about camp?
I'll just have to talk to myself like a crazy person-- AGHH!! It's a troll!
Is that a troll?
Troll's a bush
That's a bush that just looks like a troll!
Your a sack of shit!
Eugnglnn..
Euughh..
Is that a spider? Is that a branch?
Is that a TROLL? No...
Oh! Why do I need to run?
Why are you telling me that I need to run?!
Why would I- in this situation- need to run?!
Alright, Imma run then.
Here I go- AGH! Marsh!!
Oh ho ho hoo!! I hope I get some leeches!
Aghh- hahaha! There's leeches biting my nether regions!
Oh good- ah- okay, that's not good.
I do- BBRR- Why did I just-BRR- WHAT?!
Wha-?!
What?!
I drowned?! I just- I drowned. I drowned. You I just walked straight slowly into the LAGOON...
and I DROWNED!
Okay- eh- uh- excuse me for being a little incredulous about that. Heh.
... like you... okay? Alright then.
Ohh, where am I going? Good thing they set up these convenient bridges!
I don't know who did them- Hey wait, is that a power line?!
Wai-Wha-Okay! I almost drowned! -gasp-
WHAAAAYYY-- WHAT THE FUCK ARE--?! YEAY! YEAY I'M I'M I'm
I'm in the-- I'm gonna drown now. Okay, alright.
Well, okay, alright. AhhhhHHHhhhHHHhh..
Okay I didn't know that this was a swamp from "Lord of the Rings"...
The one with all the GHOSTS in the water!
Alrighty then...
Okie-dokie then...
Alllriiighty then...
So that's how it's going to be-- and what's with this CAR?!!
Oh! The car's being used as a generator! Oh! Okay! Alrighty then-- OO!
Free flash light? No. Question mark..
Ohhh! Fuses? Ohhh!!
Oooo! Heheheh!
Okay, alright, okay, I got this!
I got this.
Look, it's all going the right-- or the left, but there's nothing over there so it's all gotta go to the--
It's all gotta go to the right!
Right?...
nnnNOPE!
Alright! Okay! That's no good! Okay so, I need to find some fuses me thinks.
But what is this building? Is it like some kind of a fort or something? Is there a way in?
Can I go around? HELLOO-- OOHH I can! Ahh! Goodie!
You wouldn't happen perchance to have a flashlight, would you?
I think that maybe there's a lot of death in this building...
Okay, here I go! Did you happen to see a weird shadow monster? Because I sure did!
Ooh! Oh Food! Ooh a--- Ohh... Ugghh..
Nope. I like that a lot less.
I like that a lot less. Oh, boy.. That is something- uh- straight out of my nightmares.
Okay, good, good, great. OHHH! Gruel! Oh great! I love that, ah thank you!
OH! Rust! Heh!
This is just a block of rust. That's not even a can or nothin'. It's just- a BLOCK.
"The Holy Duty"...
"Th-The.. The Holy DUTY."
"Divine Sacrifice"-- The sacral rules of divine sacrifice!
Aha aha! Great! I am gonna die! I am...
going to die...
Okay, alright! Can I pick up the spoon? Okay, can...
Alright, great great great great great...
So...
I've only got one fuse. I don't know if I'm supposed to be able to---
WAH AH AH AH OHHHH!!!
I do not like you! Ugh...
God.. damnit damn ass!
You eat a bag of dicks, okay?! Alright?! Please?!
Ugh... Please make your diet predominantly dicks.
Okay, I'm gonna put a fuse in this thing and you're gonna
NOT kill me...
Talking about the middle one here...
Yeah.. yeah... Right???
OOHH! Wait! Oh I see! Ahhhh....
Okay...
Woop! Whoaaa!!!
Whoa!! Ah! Oh! OHHH!! WHOA WHOAAAA! WHA! AHHHHGHGHGHHH
Weird paper creature!!!
Full of bugs! No! No don't do-- NONOO NO NAH NAH NAAAH!! OHHHH DO DO DO DOOOOOOHHH DODODOOOOHHH!!
NO NO NO! I'M IN A BOX!!!
YOU CAN'T GET ME I'M IN A BO--
Ohhh okay, alright, ahhhhh.....
AAAHHhhhh..
You still there, buddy? You still there?
Okay! Alright! See ya...
Farewell.
FareWELLLL...
Farewell...
Oh jeez... Okay, alright then...
Nuughhugh...
Eiiyeehhehh..
Oh what is that? What is- What is that?
It's one the lost orchestra members!
Is that the "Game of Thrones" opening?
Good job. Good job there!
You're doing great.
Oh...
I- I- I got nothin' to say about that! Do you have anything to say about that?!
And for all I know I just hallucinated that from all the marsh BOG that I inhaled!
Okay, alright. Where am I going now?
WHERE am I going NOW?
WHERE'D MY BROTHER LEAVE ME???
-sigh-
K. Still going I guess...
Oh! Here we are! Where are we now?
Hi! How's it going? My name is Markiplier.
Is there anyone here that maybe... has seen one of my videos? Haha
Yeah. It's alright. Come on now! I'm a nice guy.
Hahaha!
Why am I in a cage? Why did I voluntarily put myself in a cage, and who the hell rigged up this system to pull this
cage across a marsh JUST conveniently enough to drive by the corpse playing the violin?
Eh, okay..
Nuughh.
Can I get out now? I wanna get off Mr. Bone's wild ride...
THANK you for that...
Okay- OH, what a lovely shack!
Oh, it's beautiful! Do you have any books on human sacrifice?
I was hopin'...
'Cause why not? Okay. Alright, alright.
Well I'm-- I'm gonna die...
A good! A book on sacrifices. That's exactly what I was looking for.
Weeeell, time to hit the ol' dusty trail and get into this marsh...
Uhh.. Yep, alright, here we go. I saw a path through here.
Is that a grave stone or a rock?...
It's a rock.
Who built all this? Who did this? Why did they do this?
Why here? Why did they decide that here was the best place for...
...all of this..
ugh
I mean, they must have known that it was a marsh! A BOG even... Ughh..
This is full of bad--
BROO!!
uh-oh
BRO!!!
Bro???
Bro!
Oh, can I build a bridge? Can I build a bridge? Can I build a bear? Oh.
What the hell was that?...
Oh that was like an effigy. Can I go in here? Nah? Alright fine then.
So what does this... mean? Where do I go then?
If I can't go that way then I have to find a way around I suppose...
Oh- what the- oh- OHHHHH!!!
That was not obvious- that was one hundred percent--
I had to go through a gap in the rocks? I mean, I knew those three planks of wood were illuminated, and I knew
it had to be for a reason. I just didn't know I was supposed to go through the gap.
Ohhh, okay. alright. Carrying on!
bRO!!!
BROO!!!
HELP!
Uh-oh, train tracks.
Bro?
Oh! Whooo- umm...
Uhh.. Who- uh- who would be comin' through here? Honestly?
Who do you think would be trudging their way through this???
Uhhh- this looks bad...
I mean it looks very simular to the rest of the woods, but I've got a bad feeling about it..
Oooohhhh nooo....
Oh no, I'm going into the mar--
AAAGGHHHHHHIIEENNNZZZAA!!!!
AGHH...
UGHHH!
Well that is an hell of an introduction, wouldn't you say? That is a hell of a hello.
Did you- uh- happen to see an idiot brother of mine holding a flashlight? That--
scared the ever loving jesu-- AHH!
OKAY! LOOKING BACK WOULD BE A BAD IDEA!
AAHH, okay alright then! Okay, alright, everything's fine. Everythings fine.
I mean, obviously everything would be fine. Why wouldn't it be fiiiiiinnne---....
EUGH
SSSSS.... Alright...
Okay, alright, okay.
I'm just gonna follo---...
BRAAWW??
BEHIND ME??
In front of me? I can't tell where!
Oh boy, this is bad...
That's what I would call a whole lotta BAD.
Oh no, oh no, OH NO.
OH NO.
Oh no, please don't eat me Mr. Troll...
Please don't eat me!
Please!
I'm beggin' you!
Please don't eat me!
AAAWAAAHHH!!
Eh- oh-- Is  that your stomach, or is that you?!
EEHWAHH! NO RUMBELY IN YOUR TUMMY PLEASE!
Ok. Alright.
Hello...
BRO!!!
BRO!
TELL A STORY ABOUT CAMP IT WILL PUT 'EM RIGHT TO SLEEP!
Man, who knew that this- all this stuff- this Swedish lore- was just waiting right outside the city limits!? On the way to the--
AHHH!!
REHABS!!!
Hello, hi! Okay. I don't know how I missed you, but I did!
You're big! Nice butt! Okay, goodbye! Good catchin' up with ya!
Alright see ya! Dear friend! See ya, brow!
See ya, DUUUDE..
Alright, anyway...
Gotta make my way down town... Walkin' fast
Trees passed, and I'm home bound.
Jeez, who the heck-- like why are these even lit up anymore?! It doesn't make any sense!
What was that?
WHAAAT WAS THAT?!
NAAHH!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no... None of that is necessary.
WHY IS THERE A STICK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE WATER?!
Why is any of this anywhere?
Iiieyy..
Oh, good drowned house, okay.
Good! Okay! Alright.
Okay, alright!-- Eughh..
Okay, alright.
Follow the power line? I think yes, maybe yes.
I wanna give that a whole lotta yes.
Gonna sliiide
What?! No moose to catch my fall?!
Fine then!
"Helberg Telefon". Okay, alright. Oh! Good thing this is here!
I'm glad the infrastructures reach this far outta town!
'Cause otherwise I would be boned!
Alright, is that a water tower?! Ah great!
Okay- Whoa!
Uhhhh- oh- okay...
Well...
I seem to have reached an impasse...
I'm gonna go for the tower I suppose...
Oh it's many! Oh this is creepy!
Oh this whole place, I don't like it!
Whaa..
Alright.
Well, I'm just gonna walk right through!
Not mind a thing--
Don't know why these are here! Some kinda fever dream I'm in.
Oh good a windmill! Oh! I don't know why all these ordinarily cheerful things are just so creepy in this...
land-- AAOWWW MY ANKLES- in this land of death and dead!
Oh good! I couldn't see things before, now I can see them even less.
Where'd that windmill go? Oh it's right there-- no?
Yes?-- Oh.
Well, that ain't good. Well that ain't good either.
None of that seems good. What are you?
Probably not good. Okay.
God, what is going on in these woods?
Is this like some surreal experience, brought on by whatever the hell my quote on quote addiction is,
or is this something more?
Ehh. oh!
Uh.
BRO!
Is that you?
Something tells me that- by the loud grunting sounds- it might be you.
Okay.
ALRIGHT.
OKAY.
Good, great, good, great, good. Okay.
Ugh. Excuse me as I duck!
Muuhh..
AH.
WHOA.
AAHH.
Whaaaaat--??
What was THAT?
What WAS that?
What was that?...
UH-huhuhuhhh-
Okay, alright, okay, alright.
Alright. Shut up. SHUT UP.
SHUT UP!
SHUT UP!!!
WHO'S- HEY- AH- SHUT UP!!
OH-OH! WAAAHH!! SHUT UP!!
WAAHH SHUT UP!!!
SHUT UP, SHUT UP, SHUT UP, SHUT UP, SHUT UP, SHUT UP, SHUT UP! SHH SHH SHHH!
SHH!
Okay, alright. Shut them up.
Shut those assholes up.
This is an endless woods.
Mixture of woods and marsh!
Never ending! Where's my--
EYY!
Wh- I'm shutting up currently!!
Ohh..
What happens if I walk towards it?
Bro!
Cover me! I'm goin' in!
I ju- I just can't avert my eyes from that SWEET, HYPNOTIC ASS!
I can't help it!
What are you crunching on? Ah God he's about--
AHH!!
WOOO! HIII!! OOHH NO! OH GOD! OH AHH YOU'RE UGLY.
Ah, okay, whatever.
Welp there I go.
Anyway, that's all the time I've got for this episode.
But I am going to finish this game. This is wonderful. You know, ordinarily, it was very much like- a lot of walking in this first episode. But somehow it kept it interesting the whole time.
And I don't know how.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching. If you want to play this for yourself, I will provide a link to it in the description bellow.
Let me know what you thought down in the comments, and thanks again for watching.
And as always, I will see YOU in the next video! Bye Bye!